i was reading um bob lefsetz's email
newsletter and he was saying that bad
company is not in the rock and roll hall
of fame and i was like
wow that is weird to me yeah what does
it take
would you please tell us
gary votes and gary did you not vote for
a bad company why not
i don't get i'm not on the nominating
committee i only get to vote on who they
give us
they've given no i think they have no
they haven't i've never seen him
i've never seen him on the ballot
imagine this here's your nightmare
like you're paul rogers you beat the
odds you're in a band called bad company
you've sold
millions and millions of albums and you
can sing your ass off
and then one day he's sitting at home
and he finds out
gary de la bate is in charge of whether
he gets into the rock and roll hall of
fame
and he's sitting there and he's like
what the [ __ ] is my life come to me
and then he calls his buddy goes hey i
understand we're up again it's
our 19th year we're up again for rock
and roll hall of fame uh
what have you heard i heard uh it all
comes down to gary dela beta
gary gary dela
gary de la bicho oh i didn't know the
guy from the howard stern show works in
rock and roll oh no no he doesn't he
listens to a lot of music
erin you know that i'm one of 700 people
that votes and no one whatever has
ever not gotten in by one vote paul we
got word that gary
creates a lot of music lists though okay
good i thought maybe he didn't have any
credibility i didn't know
he kept less amused what else can you
tell me about gary dela beatty that he's
controlling my future in the rock roll
hall of fame
well well he hosts he hosts something
called the wrap-up show
is that a music show yeah no he talks
about howard stern
a gradius really wow
it doesn't sound to me like he's
qualified to vote on my life's work
he doesn't work in rock but he
alphabetizes his vinyl
oh you mean he has a vinyl collection
that's right
bad company goes under b if he had any
bad company
i hope he does i do hey
if it makes you feel better he worked at
a record store for a few months like 40
years ago
he did order 99 luff balloons
for the record store oh really you mean
in other words
he didn't write 99 left balloons he
ordered it for the store and was
responsible for getting it in the store
oh now i understand
gary's never written a song but many
song parodies have been written about
his teeth
oh i see so he's inspired people yes yes
very much so oh good okay is he at least
a good judge of things like like
what did he think when the ipad came out
is the i've had a
another breakthrough for apple uh i
don't know that it's a breakthrough for
them
in fact i think in a lot of ways it was
a bit of a stumble for them
oh oh gary thought it was a bit of a
stumble he thought it wouldn't do well
he'll decide my faith at the rock and
roll hall of fame yes he's one of 700.